Well,
I have the pleasure of introducing to you today,
Stephen Schwarzman,
who has kindly agreed to lecturer class.
Uh,
Mr Schwartzman,
uh,
graduated from Yale in 1969.
He was at Davenport College.
Do we have any Davenport people here?
And a few,
not,
not a lot.
Uh,
he graduated then from a Harvard Business School in 1972.
he worked at Lehman Brothers,
um,
as,
I don't think it was his first job or one of his first jobs,
uh,
and became managing director at Lehman Brothers at age 31.
Uh,
and he became head of their global mergers and acquisitions team in 1985.
Mr Schwartzman,
uh,
with Peter Peterson founded the Blackstone group,
which has become the lead manager of alternative assets.
Uh,
in some sense what he does and what,
uh,
David Swensen does,
whom we had heard from earlier this semester is similar.
They're both looking at unusual and different investment assets.
Uh,
and they are both very successful.
And doing this,
uh,
Mr Schwartzman's firm has,
had a return on private equity investments of 23% a year,
uh,
for the last,
on average for the last 20 years.
Uh,
this is,
uh,
a little bit in excess of David Swenson,
but I think we have to put them both as a remarkable,
uh,
investors in the real estate group at Blackstone,
they've had 30% a year for the last 15% for the last 15 years.
And this is after fees.
Uh,
so,
um,
uh,
Blackstone group has been very much in the news recently.
It just came out,
um,
that,
uh,
they are,
apparently they're going to be buying a 12 point $5 billion of leveraged loans
from Citi Group,
uh,
at,
at a steep discount.
Uh,
and so currently they've seen a profit opportunity there,
or they're supporting our economy from the ravages of the subprime crisis.
Also,
in the news,
China has announced that it plans to buy $3 billion stake in Blackstone group,
uh,
as,
it's first a effort to diversify.
It's a one point $2 trillion of foreign exchange reserves.
So the Blackstone group was picked by the Chinese government as the most fitting
place for it to put.
Some of it's a reserves.
So with that,
I will,
uh,
leave it to Mr Schwarzman who will speak,
for a while.
Thank you very much for coming out on a,
what's a bit of a dreary,
uh,
slightly rainy morning,
when I was in a,
an undergraduate,
uh,
we wouldn't have gotten much of an attendance.
People would've been sleeping in.
Uh,
so,
uh,
it's,
it's awful nice of you to be here.
Uh,
there,
there are some dramatic differences,
uh,
from when I was an undergraduate and you are a,
one of the first differences is that this course wouldn't have existed because
no one had an interest in finance.
Uh,
uh,
at that time I wasn't a particularly interesting,
time,
uh,
in the,
in the 1960s,
uh,
the securities markets a actually we're,
we're,
we're regulated,
uh,
you know,
commissions were fixed on the New York Stock Exchange.
So it was very difficult to find some way to compete.
It was sort of a rig system,
if you will.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
it wasn't,
wasn't open.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and so there was very little to no interest,
really,
uh,
in,
finance,
uh,
you know,
there,
there really wasn't,
uh,
a,
an som,
uh,
school of Management,
at Yale,
uh,
at that point,
business,
uh,
generally was utterly unfashionable.
Uh,
we were in the midst of the Vietnam War.
and,
uh,
business was a sort of linked to the perception of that war because they
supplied,
you know,
certain types of,
uh,
you know,
a warm materials and,
and that was the,
the most unfashionable thing that you could be involved with.
So there was a very antibusiness,
uh,
non-existent finance orientation,
at,
at the school.
And obviously that's changed in the society,
uh,
generally with,
enormous,
uh,
differences.
And,
and as a result of when I grew up,
uh,
I didn't even take an economics course at Yale.
I,
I frankly wasn't much good with math.
Uh,
I,
I stopped in the 11th grade and,
um,
you know,
I,
I think calculus was,
was for me that was way too much of a reach.
So I'm more in the add,
subtract,
multiply,
and divide kind of a category a which,
which worked and still does,
uh,
you know,
quite well,
uh,
for me.
And,
uh,
when,
when I graduated,
um,
I was lucky enough to get a job at,
uh,
at a,
a firm that had just gone public.
It was the first New York Stock Exchange firm that had just gone public.
It was called Donaldson,
Lufkin and Jenrette.
Uh,
and,
uh,
Bill Donaldson actually founded the School of Management,
after he left.
Uh,
Dlj,
uh,
and,
and that was because this is a financial markets course that,
that was quite interesting for me because I,
I didn't even know what,
what common stock was,
uh,
when,
when I graduated,
uh,
hopefully you will have learned more in this course.
And,
and I,
I went to deal,
Jack couldn't read a financial statement,
which is like going to a foreign country,
not being able to speak a language.
It was sort of hopeless.
Uh,
but,
but one of the interesting experiences I had a about which,
which really now that I'm a little bit older and can look backwards,
uh,
on,
on financial markets,
uh,
it was,
was my first visit to accompany and Dlj basically is,
was one of the first large institutional stock managers,
uh,
of a pension fund assets and so forth.
And,
um,
I was allowed to go and interview,
uh,
a,
a company I'd never interviewed a company executive.
And I read their annual report and I went up to see this,
uh,
gentlemen,
and,
um,
uh,
and,
I,
I sat there and I figured out all the things I'd want to know so that,
so that I could figure out whether I should buy his stock or invest in his
company.
And I went through my list of questions and he wouldn't answer most of them.
And,
uh,
I,
I found it a very frustrating experience.
And I,
I went back to the office and by the time I got back to the office,
uh,
Dick Jenrette,
who was president of the firm,
had gotten in and rage phone call from this,
uh,
executive and,
um,
uh,
and called me into his office and he said,
Geez,
you guys made this man very angry.
I said,
well,
how could I do that?
I was just asking questions.
Uh,
and he wasn't answering them.
So I just like ask the question again.
Uh,
you know,
I couldn't quite understand why he wasn't answering me.
He said,
well,
you were asking him things that he's not allowed to answer.
I said,
what do you mean?
He said,
well,
you were asking him for inside information.
I said,
well,
I don't know what insight information is.
I'm just asking the question that I need to know to know the answer,
whether to buy the stock or not.
Uh,
and he said,
well,
Steve,
there are all these rules of what you can answer it,
ask somebody.
And then if he tells you that he has to tell everybody in the world,
and,
and you know,
that's just too cumbersome.
And so,
uh,
you know,
that's why he didn't answer.
I said,
well,
if he didn't answer,
how in the world can you figure out what to do?
Uh,
and I said,
I,
I'm not that smart.
I need to have all relevant data and,
and he's the person who has it,
so why won't he give it to me?
And it became pretty clear that I was doing the wrong thing for a living.
Uh,
and,
uh,
in effect,
that's the dilemma for people who want to buy a liquid securities.
And I decided very quickly this was a bad business.
Uh,
uh,
certainly a bad one for me that I couldn't figure out how I could win that game.
Uh,
you know,
when somebody wouldn't fully share openly everything they knew,
uh,
and,
um,
uh,
I guess if you were like,
assume or with a good fashion sense,
uh,
you know,
that,
that that's how you manage liquid securities and beat other people.
It's not just what,
you know,
it's,
it's a question of whether the rest of the world will buy into what you know and
drive that security up.
And so I,
uh,
basically retreated a and went to Harvard business school where I figured maybe
somebody will tell me how this game really works in a way that,
uh,
I can prosper in it.
Uh,
and,
uh,
that was a good experience for me.
Um,
uh,
and,
um,
they basically taught you and your undergraduate,
so you don't know what they're teaching you at a school like that.
So I can explain it actually pretty clearly.
It's,
it's,
it's basically they're teaching you that everything you do with the company has
something,
uh,
else to do with that company.
So,
so that it's an integrated system.
so,
so that,
uh,
if you,
um,
are trying to develop a product for sale,
it would be good to know whether somebody wants it.
Right.
Uh,
so,
you know,
what happens actually in the real world,
uh,
is that sometimes people just get an interesting idea and they'll produce a
product and nobody would want it.
And if you,
if you,
uh,
integrate all the different kinds of knowledge in,
in the company so that you're doing intelligent things,
and I know this appears very elementary,
you'll have a better company.
That's sort of what they were teaching.
And after they taught that for like two or three months,
I sorta got it,
uh,
and thought about dropping out of school because it got a little repetitive.
Um,
frankly,
uh,
but I was convinced,
by,
by my friend Dick Jenrette who also thought about dropping out of Harvard
Business School,
uh,
in December,
it gets very cold in Boston,
uh,
and really miserable.
And he was going to drop out and go and get a phd in economics.
I was going to drop out and go back to the real world.
And you know,
he,
he said that his staying on was a good thing and I should stay on.
And,
and so,
uh,
I did,
what I've sort of done for a career is trying to solve that problem of my
initial meeting,
uh,
where,
people will,
uh,
I want people to tell me what's really going on so I can figure out,
you know,
whether what they're saying makes sense or doesn't make sense.
Uh,
and,
and you can do that,
uh,
in,
in the private equity business,
which was sort of our largest business.
Uh,
and you could do that in the real estate business because you're,
you're allowed to get all that inside information if you're trying to buy a
company with our rules and also the rules of other companies,
countries,
if you sign a
confidentiality agreement that you won't use that information for any purpose
other than buying the company and putting a price on it.
And then the shareholders get a chance to vote on whether they want the price
that you give them.
Uh,
and,
and so,
uh,
you know,
to me that was that,
that was like an answer to my conundrum of how can I,
how can we get all the information and then figure out what to do with it,
including improving the company.
Uh,
I'm,
I'm sure you know something about private equity.
Uh,
if you read the general newspapers,
I'll tell you basically what it is.
We're,
all we do is we,
we,
uh,
we buy companies.
Uh,
and,
and that's the simplest thing we do.
We do a lot of other things.
But let's start with,
you know,
we buy companies,
uh,
we borrow money to buy those companies.
Uh,
historically,
uh,
it's been about a $3 of debt for every $1 of equity.
We then improve those,
uh,
companies,
you know,
through a whole variety of,
uh,
you know,
sort of managerial actions.
Uh,
and then those companies grow with the general economy.
And let's say if they just grow at the regular rate of all companies,
uh,
then,
if you're leveraged three,
two,
one,
you're going to earn a much better return.
Uh,
if you take a company and can accelerate its growth,
so it's growing faster because you've improved it and you have three to one
leverage,
you'll,
you'll get a way better return than,
than any normal,
uh,
stock market,
kind of return.
Uh,
and,
and that sort of the model,
uh,
of what we do in that business.
Uh,
uh,
as Professor Sheila was saying,
we've,
we've compounded,
uh,
after fees at 23%,
but before fees,
uh,
because we,
we charge a 20%,
uh,
part of the profits of the deal goes back to the general partner,
which is us.
Uh,
we,
we've actually earned around 31%.
Uh,
uh,
which,
you know,
from you being in a course like this you'd see is that's really pretty high.
Uh,
you know,
compared to a stock market average over a period,
which would be around the 11th.
And,
and in real estate.
Um,
W W we do the same kind of thing.
Uh,
but,
but real estate is an easier business,
uh,
because buildings don't talk,
managements of companies talk a,
and you have to figure out what they're saying.
Companies are very complex.
Uh,
you know,
you have interesting competition.
You have global competition.
Uh,
it's,
it's a complicated,
uh,
asset class.
Real,
real estate is very simple.
I mean,
you know,
there,
there's,
uh,
you know,
building stone talk.
Uh,
and so you,
you can't get misled by a building.
They can't tell you something.
They don't have a belief system and it's just there.
It's on the corner,
it's in the middle of the block.
Uh,
uh,
and,
and there are other buildings that either getting built or planned,
uh,
and,
and you can figure out what the supply demand is for real estate in a much
easier way.
Uh,
and,
uh,
because of that,
our,
our returns in real estate have been a better cause.
It's an easier asset class.
Uh,
and,
and we,
we've earned after fees 30% a year since we started,
uh,
and before fees close to 40%.
So this alternative asset class,
if,
if handled right,
is,
is really a much better way,
uh,
of,
of earning money,
uh,
for,
for investors as well as the general partner.
Let's not forget us,
uh,
that then a regular financial markets,
investing,
uh,
and,
you know,
that world,
uh,
it has been started very small.
Uh,
when we started at institutions had less than 1% of their assets.
It was like in fantastical,
uh,
in,
in the private equity side of the business.
Uh,
it's now up to about four and a half percent.
and the returns are so much higher.
You'd wonder why,
uh,
people don't give us all their money,
on,
on an asset allocation basis.
And I,
I actually still wonder why they don't,
uh,
since we put most of our money in that and we keep making more and more,
and outperforming and,
you know,
it just takes the rest of the world,
apparently the equivalent of your lifetime,
uh,
to sort of figure out exactly what they should be doing.
And,
and,
you know,
I think the projections are that,
that this should be growing at a a lot faster,
uh,
rate,
you know,
going into the future.
Uh,
and,
uh,
some institutions like Yale have,
private equity with,
around,
and I guess it's around 16,
17%.
It was up to 18,
uh,
of their portfolio.
And that's one of the reasons why Dave Swenson has done a much better,
uh,
than a regular money managers,
turning to a different subject.
It's a financial markets course.
And I thought it would be useful to talk to you a little bit about what's really
going out in the real world,
even though this course is,
is,
is being,
uh,
recorded,
you know,
and whatever you say about the,
the,
the current moment,
it turns out to be right or wrong,
but it's just a current moment.
It's such a fascinating one.
Uh,
and,
and you all are,
I guess,
somewhere between
18 and 21 years old,
probably 19 and 19 and 21.
So,
so you don't have the perspective to understand how really,
uh,
interesting and dangerous.
Uh,
this current environment,
uh,
is,
what,
what's happened,
uh,
is,
is that,
um,
through,
uh,
an abnormal,
in issuance of something called subprime securities.
Nobody in this audience,
certainly people watching,
uh,
you know,
probably own a house.
Um,
uh,
and,
and what happened is that in the late nineties,
the government,
uh,
in Washington,
we passed the law to encourage more,
uh,
low income people being able to buy houses and resulted,
along with other factors in an explosion of,
of these types of loans in terms of,
of loans.
And Professor Shiller can correct me if I'm slightly off on this,
but in the year 2002 of the total mortgage mortgage loans that were originated,
a four,
four,
four houses,
uh,
probably around two to 3% of them have more subprime.
Uh,
um,
and these are for people who don't have enough money to really pay normal
principal or interest and,
and,
and expect,
uh,
their,
their mortgage to be current,
to not go into default.
And by 2006,
this had exploded a to 30% of,
of all the mortgages that were issued that year.
When you go to two,
from two to 3% to 30%,
this is,
this is an almost out of body experience,
uh,
and,
um,
to,
to entice these people to take these loans.
Uh,
they,
they actually,
um,
uh,
would tell somebody in the olden days when,
when I was your age to buy a house,
you had to put up like 25% of the cost of the house.
Uh,
you know,
sometimes you,
you'd have to put up a 20% of the cost of the house and you can borrow 80,
uh,
the subprime loans.
Sometimes you,
you only had to put up 3% of the cost of the house.
you didn't even have to put up anything.
Uh,
that makes it really affordable.
and,
and then,
uh,
you didn't have to pay any interest for,
for two or three years.
So you put up nothing and you paid nothing.
So this led to,
um,
you know,
a stampede of people who wanted this.
And what's happening now,
uh,
is,
is that,
uh,
the mortgage,
the interest,
which no one,
uh,
a lot of these mortgages didn't have to pay.
Now two to three years later,
you have to pay it.
And a lot of the people who didn't have the resources can't pay the mortgages.
Those mortgages are defaulting.
Uh,
the,
the issue that created all the problems in the financial system that you're
reading about in the front page is that these mortgages were pooled in,
in,
in a new security.
You know,
imagine just sort of a jar where somebody threw out a few thousand of these
mortgages and then put the lid on it.
Um,
and,
and so,
um,
they,
they had these new securities and what they did is they said,
well,
the first 83% of them must be really safe because mortgage is basically hardly
ever default.
And they rated those,
the rating agencies,
which tell people how secure something is a rated this as a triple a security.
And the world of finance,
when you tell somebody that that is security is,
is AAA.
They get rated all the way from triple A's down to triple C's.
And triple c means something's about to blow up a.
And AAA means there's no possible chance you're ever going to lose your money.
And so,
because 83% of this jar was rated,
uh,
you know,
AAA people bought this all over the world as if it was a security that could
never,
ever,
ever default.
And as you can see,
um,
you know,
these were basically mortgages made to,
to,
to low income people who weren't even paying,
in some cases interest on it.
And the chance that these were going to default was really sky high.
Uh,
historians will go back and figure out why anybody would believe that these
things could be AAA.
Uh,
but,
but they did and they were bought everywhere.
So th this,
these,
these securities became like American SARS.
Uh,
you know,
they were exported throughout the world creating enormous problems,
uh,
for individual institutions.
Uh,
you know,
around the world and in the United States,
they,
they've created what will be hundreds of billions of dollars of losses for the
financial institutions.
And,
uh,
as part of Sarbanes Oxley,
which was a law passed,
uh,
you know,
after Enron and some other things,
we've developed accounting procedures with something called a very technical
called fas,
a one 57,
which is called fair value accounting,
which means you,
before these defaults even happen,
the fact that other people think they're going to happen results in the
securities being worth less than you have to take a loss based on that expected
value.
So the financial institutions,
we're losing all this money without the defaults even happening or people
knowing how that it would be a,
and as a result of that,
those large losses,
um,
the financial market started losing confidence in some of the financial
institutions and different asset classes in those,
uh,
financial institutions.
Principally,
banks started trading in a really bad way.
People thought they were gonna,
you know,
be forced to sell some of those.
Uh,
and we had a variety of different asset classes are ranging from municipal
bonds.
Um,
uh,
basically,
you know,
changing their value.
People said,
I don't want these anymore.
There were hedge funds that own those on leverage.
So,
so there were a margin calls which forced those securities to be sold,
which made them worse,
worth even less,
uh,
that got the banks even more nervous,
nervous,
uh,
that resulted in higher rated securities being sold that were also on leverage.
Uh,
and what you had was like panic selling of securities rolling through every
element of the financial system as people desperately tried to get out of stuff
before we become worth less.
And,
and this type of rapid,
uh,
leveraging resulted in,
in a downward valuations for all these securities.
A lot of hedge funds going,
um,
uh,
bankrupt.
Anyone with leverage by borrowing more than five to one to carry some very
secure real securities.
Uh,
not,
not subprime,
but government oriented securities.
Um,
uh,
you know,
the,
those institutions got into trouble.
And what we've had is,
is basically melt in the financial markets where,
uh,
the banks have been so severely impacted,
that they have stopped lending to certain whole asset classes.
Uh,
you know,
particularly leverage lending,
which we're involved with,
uh,
as well as other areas.
Uh,
the costs of credit have gone up,
you know,
sort of,
um,
uh,
three,
3%,
4%,
which doesn't sound like much to you,
but it actually in the overall system is a lot.
And what that's resulted in is a financial crisis.
It's resulted in,
um,
uh,
the Federal Reserve who's the ultimate protector of the system.
Very quickly lowering interest rates,
agreeing to lend huge amounts of money,
uh,
to the banking system because banks are now now not even lending money to each
other.
They're,
they're sufficiently scared about what's going on.
Uh,
and the Federal Reserve is saying,
well,
everybody can come to me a and I'll lend you all money,
uh,
to keep you liquid.
So this whole system doesn't stop.
Uh,
now as it impacts regular people is,
is when the financial institutions go into a crisis like this,
uh,
and stop lending or reduce their lending of money.
There's less money for regular people to borrow to go about their lives.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
in businesses to get,
and as that starts happening,
uh,
an economy will slow down,
and,
and go into a recession.
Uh,
and,
and that's what's happening,
uh,
in the United States.
So for those of you who are graduating this year,
uh,
your prospect of getting a job will be less than the people who graduated last
year.
Uh,
and the people who graduated the year before had a much better deal than the
ones that were graduating,
uh,
last year.
Uh,
and,
and this is a,
uh,
a problem that's pretty pervasive one,
and,
uh,
and it will probably take longer to get out of this recession than other ones,
that,
uh,
that we've had.
Uh,
and the implications of,
you know,
financial markets,
which may sound like just sort of a,
a,
a dry academic course.
Uh,
this will also affect the outcome of presidential elections among other things.
because you'll see that from what the presidential candidates started talking
about nine months ago,
which is a lot of foreign policy,
a war in Iraq.
What should we be doing about a variety of those issues?
You'll see that by the time this election,
uh,
occurs that the focus will be,
much more,
uh,
and perhaps dominantly so,
on the economy,
uh,
on people defaulting and being thrown out of their houses,
on,
uh,
you know,
what's happening to the economy.
Generally it's going to hit other things such as a trade and,
uh,
you know,
the country being more populist,
uh,
more protectionist.
Uh,
which also has negative implications,
uh,
because,
the United States right now is the largest debtor nation in the world.
Uh,
10 years ago we were the largest creditor.
And when you're the largest debtor,
that means you have to borrow money all the time from people in the outside
world.
And if we become more protectionist and,
and,
and outsiders,
uh,
basically say,
look,
these Americans are starting to like not have an open world.
And I'm worried that maybe I won't be able to get my money back,
or,
you know,
they don't really want me to be part of their,
their world.
Uh,
then,
then there's the potential that they will invest less with us,
which again,
we'll raise our cost of borrowing in financial markets,
whether they're for treasuries or other types of things,
which will have the effect of,
again,
slowing,
uh,
our economy.
So you,
you all are about to enter the world in a very,
very,
very interesting time.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the problems with our financial institutions,
are perhaps,
uh,
the,
the greatest,
uh,
that we've had,
since,
uh,
the,
the 1930s in the era of the Great Depression,
which is when my dad,
uh,
was,
sort of a young man.
Uh,
and,
and he grew up,
uh,
in the 1930s.
And anyone who did,
uh,
um,
you know,
would,
would tell you that was just a disastrous economic time because those financial
institutions,
as opposed to struggling the way ours are,
and ours will ultimately be fine.
Uh,
those financial institutions collapsed because they didn't have the kind of,
uh,
sort of safeguards that the system has,
basically,
uh,
put into our system.
Currently,
we learned from the 1930s how to avoid a complete collapse of the financial
institutions.
Uh,
but this is a trying time for these,
um,
uh,
for the system.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the Federal Reserve is doing a really excellent job at,
at,
at sort of guaranteeing it.
And if you read about the recent bear Stearns a crisis,
uh,
which was front page of,
literally every newspaper in the world,
um,
where the,
the Federal Reserve,
uh,
stepped in and basically provided sufficient guarantees and credit support.
So this one institution wouldn't,
wouldn't go bankrupt.
Uh,
and,
and there were,
uh,
it's a brokerage firm.
Brokerage firms are not regulated by the Federal Reserve and they don't have
access to the borrowings of the Federal Reserve.
To protect them,
uh,
which,
is,
uh,
you know,
there it's sort of outside the system.
And the reason why the Federal Reserve went and did that,
uh,
is that,
that the large brokerage firms,
which don't have the same kind of regulation or the same kind of ultimate
lender,
uh,
literally have trillions and trillions of dollars of,
of,
of uh,
counterparty risk,
uh,
you know,
sort of guarantees that they've given that they'll do something.
Uh,
and if they go bankrupt,
they can't do it.
And that leaves the system vulnerable,
uh,
to,
people expecting performance on things like credit default swaps and things that
are too technical to actually explain to you at the moment.
Uh,
but they,
there are so many trillions of dollars of those obligations that if they get
into trouble,
this isn't just like a subprime mortgage.
These are in the trillions.
Uh,
and you know,
um,
uh,
and,
and just credit to fault swaps or,
uh,
about $45 trillion and the sub prime mortgage losses will only be a few hundred
billion dollars.
So the Fed was basically going in and say,
we can't take this risk to our overall system.
And that's one reason why the stock market has gotten better because the
prospect of a collapse of the system has been really reduced.
Uh,
I wasn't trying to depress you on a,
uh,
early,
morning.
Uh,
the American system is enormously resilient.
and,
uh,
you know,
there will be,
uh,
solutions that happen over time,
that will deal with this.
Uh,
but the impact of financial markets,
which is your course,
I'm just a visitor,
uh,
is,
is really,
uh,
driving,
you know,
the whole overall economy and is affecting the global economy.
Uh,
uh,
the countries in Asia,
you know,
China,
India in particular as large ones,
uh,
W W we'll obviously sustain lower growth rates as a result of this,
financial markets problem here in the United States.
Uh,
you're seeing,
uh,
the UK,
having already a slowed down,
uh,
and,
and this will probably,
uh,
as it has historically rolled into continental Europe and resulted in the whole
world,
uh,
you know,
growing slower,
higher unemployment,
uh,
and people being adversely affected.
So how financial markets work and how they're impacted and what would have
happened if,
um,
the subprime mortgages wouldn't have been allowed to have been made from a
regulatory point of view.
And what would have happened if they were,
instead of being rated AAA,
they would have been rated,
uh,
you know,
sort of,
uh,
single be hardly anybody would have bought them.
Uh,
and that would have controlled the expansion and the a risk to the financial
system.
Uh,
you know,
historians will look back on it and real people,
and not that historians aren't,
but real practitioners,
we'll,
we'll try and solve this problem,
uh,
by,
by having different types of regulation,
uh,
so,
so that you can't get into this kind of risk posture.
So in any case,
uh,
what,
why don't we,
uh,
you know,
take some questions.
That's a,
that's an opening.
Uh,
and we can talk about anything you'd like to
dare to be great.
Yes.
I,
the question was,
can,
can I take you through a good deal and a bad deal in I s I assume private equity
or,
uh,
you know,
to show you how this works.
Um,
uh,
well,
um,
uh,
a good deal.
Um,
those are always more fun by the way.
Uh,
a good deal.
it was really a,
our first deal,
uh,
it was a company called us steel corporation,
which is sort of a big one.
Uh,
was attacked by a corporate raider named Carl Icahn,
who I think you have some familiarity with.
Uh,
and uh,
being a prior speaker and a,
the corporation didn't want to be taken over.
And so they were trying to marshal cash,
uh,
to fight him off.
And the way they chose to fight him off was,
was,
was by buying their own stock,
uh,
at a higher price to give their shareholders the equivalent of a really big
dividend,
but doing it by buying their stock,
which gave them capital gains treatment.
So they needed to get a bunch of money.
So the way they thought about getting some money was to sell one of their big
assets.
And the asset they chose to sell was,
um,
uh,
their,
their railroads and,
and,
and barge lines,
uh,
and,
you know,
uh,
or boats on the Great Lakes and to make steel,
for those of you who've never done it,
um,
uh,
it's,
it's a,
it's a lot like cooking.
You need,
you know,
a variety of different ingredients,
uh,
and,
you know,
the ingredients instead of just being carried into your house in a,
in a,
in a shopping bag,
come in on a railroad because their iron ore and coke and all these really heavy
things.
Uh,
and,
uh,
in,
I guess around,
uh,
1880 1890,
a fella named Andrew Carnegie who owned a US steel,
it was then called Carnegie Steel,
built all these railroads.
So to bring this stuff in.
Uh,
and so,
so us steel,
you know,
wanting to sell it,
uh,
and they didn't want to lose control of it because they felt if that was a
lifeline artery into their steel plants were brought in 100% of the raw
materials to make steel and took out about 85,
90% of the finished product,
because steel is like really heavy,
right?
So,
you know,
you just can't carry it out and put it on a truck,
necessarily goes out by railroad.
Also,
that because this was an artery that went right into the company.
Uh,
and,
and if,
if we started overcharging,
uh,
for,
for the railroad,
they were worried that we would bankrupt the steel companies.
We'd Siphon off all the profit.
So we did a partnership deal where we own 51% of the railroads in effect a,
they own 49.
Uh,
and,
um,
uh,
we,
show you how excessive finance can get a,
it was a,
I believe that the deal was a somewhere around,
uh,
you know,
600,
$1 million,
$700 million in 1980.
Uh,
88,
89.
So that's a lot more money today.
Uh,
and,
uh,
we,
we borrowed,
uh,
almost,
you know,
all the money.
Um,
you know,
I think we put up like 15 or $20 million.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so,
so the leverage was,
was huge.
Uh,
the business wasn't particularly a growth business.
It was pretty stable.
We bought it in the middle of a strike.
So part of the art of what we did was guessing whether us steel would come back
to the same production level,
uh,
that they were before.
Uh,
and you know,
our guest slash analysis was correct.
Uh,
and every year the profits from that company would be worth more than the amount
of money that we invested,
uh,
in the equity.
And so we ended up making,
uh,
24 times our money in that deal,
in,
uh,
12 years.
So in our world,
and not the academic world,
if you make 24 times your money in 12 years,
this is regarded as a success.
Uh,
uh,
and,
um,
so,
so you know,
that,
that was a good one.
Um,
uh,
now a bad one,
shows you about,
you know,
a little bit about the,
the volatility and,
and danger of,
of sort of the currency markets.
We,
uh,
in in 19,
I guess it was a 98,
uh,
bought,
um,
it might've been 97 and 98 bought,
uh,
you know,
control of the second biggest cellular phone company,
uh,
in,
um,
uh,
Argentina.
Uh,
which,
uh,
was an interesting place to be.
You know,
I'm sure you all have one of these.
If you don't have something more elegant,
uh,
you know,
some other,
sort of personal device,
you know,
like one of these that can,
get email or it can,
you know,
you can talk on it.
You know,
I,
you can almost set it up as a disco.
You can do almost anything with it.
Uh,
that,
um,
we,
we bought this company,
uh,
for,
eight times,
uh,
cashflow,
which is not real high for a company that's growing very rapidly in,
in what was called in emerging markets,
uh,
country.
Uh,
this particular country had its currency index to the dollar.
so it was almost like,
uh,
investing in,
in,
in the United States because what can go wrong,
a rapidly growing country invested,
uh,
in dollars.
We borrowed dollars to buy this company.
Uh,
because in Argentina,
you couldn't borrow money for a long time.
One of the,
one of the great things about the United States financial markets is that you
can borrow debt for long periods of time.
Uh,
and,
uh,
this looked to be a very low risk,
rapidly growing situation where we were hopeful we were going to make four to
five times their money.
Uh,
there was only one problem,
uh,
that,
Argentina,
the country collapsed.
Uh,
and,
uh,
I mean,
literally collapsed.
Uh,
you know,
the,
the linkage,
which is called the peg to the dollar turned out to be a most unfortunate,
uh,
thing.
Uh,
and,
uh,
the emerging markets.
This is when you started with the Russian financial crisis and this crisis,
and you had an Asian financial crisis.
It rolled through the whole world with currencies rapidly changing their values.
Um,
uh,
all kinds of,
countries at risk of,
of,
of collapse.
Uh,
it got to Argentina and the whole whole economy pulverized.
It was like a depression.
And they,
they got off of their linkage to the dollar.
Uh,
their currency became close to worth nothing.
and then we had to pay our debt back in dollars with earnings in Argentina,
which were like worth nothing.
And we lost every,
uh,
every cent,
every,
every dollar we invested in,
in that,
uh,
investment.
Uh,
and,
and even as we were going bankrupt,
it was still a good company.
So,
you know,
in finance,
bad things can happen to nice people.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
even when you think things through,
you can have some really,
uh,
you know,
bad,
uh,
bad outcomes.
Um,
you know,
we,
we've had,
uh,
obviously if you have very high returns,
you have wonderful stories.
Uh,
many more wonderful,
uh,
you know,
stories than,
than bad ones.
We,
we bought a chemical company called Celanese,
um,
in about 2003 right after the recession was lifting.
It was a,
uh,
a company in Germany,
but it had only 10% of its activities in Germany.
It had about 60% of them in the United States.
So it was really a US company masquerading as a German company.
Uh,
and,
um,
the price earnings multiples of German chemical companies were very low.
The price earnings companies of,
um,
American companies were much higher.
Uh,
and,
uh,
so,
you know,
not,
not being entirely dimwitted.
Uh,
what,
what we did was,
was we changed the location of the company,
the headquarters from Germany to the United States.
They also were,
for some reason that we didn't completely understand,
had three headquarters operations going to in the United States.
One in Germany.
We closed two of those three.
We invested a lot more money in a expansion as we were coming out of a
recession.
Uh,
we,
we leveraged the company pretty highly.
Uh,
and,
and we made,
uh,
I guess it was about six times our money,
in,
uh,
two years,
owning Celanese,
uh,
which is,
on the New York Stock Exchange now.
And it's a,
it's a lovely company,
Wonderful Company.
Um,
uh,
and,
and there are many stories,
uh,
of,
of that type,
uh,
where we,
invest more money,
move things around,
uh,
borrow a lot of money,
catch fundamentals as they're going up.
Uh,
and it's,
the good stories are really,
uh,
a lot of fun.
Um,
you know,
we enjoy those.
Uh,
and,
and so to our,
uh,
investors.
So those are,
I gave you two winners and one loser instead of one on one.
Uh,
because,
uh,
in our real estate business,
we've probably,
uh,
just to give you perspective,
we,
we've only lost money on two situations,
uh,
in,
in our history,
uh,
out of about 160 investments.
So,
so the number of good stories to bad stories,
I mean,
this isn't like Las Vegas,
you know,
where you ended up as a net loser or it's a lot luck.
Every time you do one of these things,
you,
you have,
uh,
a team of people,
working on it,
uh,
some of whom are sort of in there,
you know,
sort of early forties,
um,
you know,
who are usually partners.
Uh,
and then,
you know,
each one of the firms like ours scales down in some kind of hierarchy.
Uh,
you know,
where you have managing directors and vice presidents and associates and
analysts,
uh,
the folks like yourself,
tend to get hired at firms like ours is analysts.
Uh,
and,
and which means you,
you,
you do,
you know,
statistical work.
And,
uh,
I guess they're called now models,
you know,
on,
uh,
on computer,
which give us an idea that if any of the variables affecting these deals change,
how will it affect the overall earnings of the company or cashflow of the
company or our ability to service the debt of that company.
Uh,
and,
um,
uh,
and then we can figure out from doing that what price we'd want to pay for the
company.
Uh,
how much debt we can safely put on it,
uh,
so that the business doesn't get in trouble.
Uh,
and now,
you know,
the,
this analyst program,
the firms like ours have,
and people all over Wall Street have a,
is,
is like a huge industry for people your age.
Uh,
and,
um,
this didn't exist,
uh,
when I,
was,
was in college.
And I'm actually not that old compared to you.
I,
I sorta think I'm almost the same age,
a little older.
Uh,
but,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's amazing having people like yourselves.
I mean,
in two years you could be in my conference room,
uh,
you know,
with the other rest of the team talking about,
uh,
a live deal and,
you know,
putting in your 2 cents,
uh,
you know,
of perception,
uh,
you know,
with the,
you think something's a little more risky.
What we do at our firm.
Whenever we're considering something,
we always go around the table and ask everybody.
So,
you know,
we're not trying to intimidate,
but we figure that if somebody your age has been working on something and knows
the numbers,
you know,
uh,
sort of cold,
you'll,
you'll have some views.
Uh,
and it's always fun,
uh,
particularly for me to ask,
because that's how you start the process of learning.
Finance is a business that is an apprentice business.
It's sort of like going back to the Middle Ages,
right,
where they had guilds and you'd learn your business by apprenticing with
somebody else who's already done it.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
there's a base level of knowledge that you have to have in finance before you
can be creative.
And the only way you get that is by working with other people who've already
done it and are doing it.
And people take enormous care when working with folks like yourself.
Uh,
you know,
in terms of making sure you get the right answer,
not what I'd say,
which is different in the real world as,
as a visitor from the real world,
uh,
to you in the academic world,
one of the real differences is in the real world,
there is only one grade for every project,
which is the equivalent of a course.
And that is an,
a,
uh,
an eight grade.
And the definition of an ae isn't the same as in academics and academics.
You can get an a and I don't know what Yale's current grading curve is.
Now you can get an a,
sometimes with a 90,
you can get an a with a 92,
you can get an a with 93.
And you know,
that's sort of pretty good.
That's an a in our world in a is a hundred.
This is what's shocking to me because I wasn't a 100 kind of person.
Uh,
and my first project that I did,
I,
um,
just to give you an idea of the real,
uh,
need for excellence and perfection in what we do,
is,
um,
uh,
I was assigned to a project,
I worked on it really hard.
I wrote something up that was like a term paper,
which normally you only get to do one a year in the real world,
you know,
you get to do them every two to three weeks.
Uh,
and I submitted this thing to a gentleman named Herman Kahn who was a partner at
Lehman brothers and older partner.
Uh,
uh,
at the time when I was doing it and I sent it down to him and he was waiting for
this project.
Uh,
and um,
I,
I got a phone call about three hours later and it sort of went like this,
uh,
that says Harmon kind calling,
is this Steve Schwarzman?
I said,
yes,
it is Mister Kahn.
He said,
I got your paper.
There's a typo on page 43,
Bang.
And that is the only thing I ever heard from Herman Kahn,
a slammed phone because a comma was in the wrong place,
uh,
on this piece of work.
And I had really struggled.
Uh,
and that's all I got an angry man and a slam phone.
And I basically said,
what kind of crazy world am I in?
What is this about?
And what I learned is that any piece of work that you did that wasn't completely
correct,
you got a version of Herman Kahn in your face.
Okay.
And different people did it different ways,
but this was a radically different world.
The real world in finance than I was used to.
I was a,
a major here in something that doesn't exist,
I'm sure anymore.
Uh,
a creature of the 1960s called culture behavior.
and what we did is we had an interdisciplinary major,
uh,
with we in,
in,
in psychology,
sociology,
uh,
biology and anthropology.
In other words,
we studied how people thought and why they thought that way.
I thought that was a pretty neat thing to be doing.
And we had professors from each of those disciplines.
We had two seminars a week.
We had eight students in the major,
and we had four,
uh,
professors working with us all the time.
Uh,
so I was used to a little softer,
more lovable world,
uh,
then,
finance.
Uh,
and,
and so finance for me was shocking,
uh,
that,
that people would have to have everything correct all the time.
And,
and it,
at your level,
what you'll be doing,
uh,
you know,
that's,
um,
that's sort of what it is.
I mean,
there's,
there's no alternative.
People are Nice.
They'll help you get there,
but,
but there's no,
absolutely no flexibility in terms of getting perfect scores.
Uh,
and once you do that,
I'm giving you a little career advice here,
uh,
that you do that for about two years or three years.
And,
and,
and then after that,
you can start being more creative and,
uh,
and,
and finance can be really creative,
interesting problem solving,
uh,
a business where,
you know,
it's,
it's global.
It's fun.
Uh,
I mean,
in my last two weeks,
uh,
w where have I been?
Uh,
let's see,
uh,
certainly a new haven now.
Uh,
I was in,
uh,
Bahrain,
Kuwait,
Saudi Arabia,
Abu Dhabi,
Dubai,
Cambodia,
um,
Korea,
Ireland,
and Germany.
It's actually really interesting.
And you meet people all over the world.
Uh,
you get to see how they think about issues,
how their financial systems and their economies work.
Uh,
during that trip,
you know,
I,
I met heads of countries,
I had head of financial institutions.
Uh,
you're trying to figure out,
you know,
really the most complex stuff in the world,
which is how all these systems work and how they interact and,
and,
and ultimately what you will do,
uh,
in an individual situation based upon this immense flow of knowledge and data
and,
and cultural,
uh,
differences.
Uh,
and,
you know,
I,
I Miss China and India in this trip,
uh,
but we get them on other trips and,
and it's really a finance done appropriately is a wonderful lifetime learning,
uh,
ever changing,
exciting,
uh,
kind of,
business.
It's,
it's,
it's not like,
you know,
sort of selling socks to a department store.
Uh,
this is really a fascinating,
uh,
business.
It never stays the same.
You have so many different people in so many different countries,
making so many different kinds of decisions that you as one decision maker in
that enormously complicated matrix,
you know,
the chance that you're going to get it right,
uh,
is only because you're absorbing as much information as you can from every place
and trying to thread the needle to make a correct decision.
So it's a lot of fun.
So any of you who go from this course into,
uh,
you know,
being a practitioner,
uh,
which is sort of what I am and the real world,
it's,
it happens to have historically been quite financially rewarding,
which I guess is like,
uh,
you know,
I,
I think I used to think that was a really good thing.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
wait until the u s is like reevaluating exactly what it thinks about success.
Uh,
but,
but it's,
it's basically a good thing.
Uh,
and it's fascinating and I would encourage you,
if you have an interest in it to,
uh,
to pursue it.
Yes.
Can you speak up a little?
Wow.
Okay.
It was a question about carried interest being taxed at a lower rate.
Uh,
and,
uh,
next question is,
what,
what asset class do we think is going to have a really high returns over the
next five years on the carried question.
Um,
uh,
you know,
this is something that,
uh,
you know,
has been pretty well,
uh,
um,
you know,
sort of surface,
uh,
you know,
um,
there,
there are a bunch of arguments from different sides of the political spectrum,
uh,
on this.
Um,
you know,
folks like ourselves who have had a carried interest,
a taxed at capital gains rates since the 1930s.
Uh,
um,
you know,
we're sort of wondering where the whole discussion is coming from.
A,
in other words,
this,
this has been going on for longer than I've been alive.
Uh,
that,
um,
you know,
this has been a capital gains treatment,
uh,
item.
Uh,
the way,
uh,
carried interest works is we get a 20% a share of the profits of any investment,
over,
uh,
some type of a hurdle rate,
which is a minimum return.
Uh,
in our case,
usually it's around 8%,
uh,
to,
to get this,
uh,
a carried interest.
Um,
uh,
you know,
we have to invest significant monies,
uh,
you know,
in,
in our funds,
um,
which is totally unlike normal compensation.
Most people to get,
you know,
sort of,
some people in the government want to characterize this as normal compensation,
ordinary income.
Uh,
people get ordinary income just work and they get it.
They normally don't invest millions of dollars for the opportunity to get their
salary.
Uh,
uh,
we also,
have to,
uh,
if,
if we don't make a certain minimum return and we've gotten some of this carried
interest by the time a whole funds over,
we have to pay the carried interest back.
Um,
most people who own an ordinary income don't pay back there,
uh,
income,
after they've gotten it.
Uh,
and,
uh,
in,
a carried interest basically comes out of,
you know,
splitting the profits from a partnership where,
um,
uh,
you know,
it's,
uh,
sort of quite normal for a working partner to get more of a deal than just a
passive,
uh,
investor,
in,
you know,
whether it's somebody just in a,
in a,
in a family,
somebody works in the business,
um,
you know,
and somebody else in the family puts up the money to buy part of the business.
Usually the person working in the business gets more.
Uh,
so we,
we sort of look at this,
uh,
as a,
as sort of a,
um,
an issue that's now in the political world.
Uh,
and,
uh,
you know,
it will be solved in that world.
We don't,
we don't have much of a say,
uh,
in that.
Uh,
uh,
but I,
I would that the,
the sort of,
um,
a characterization of this as being something,
uh,
as,
as a,
uh,
you know,
sort of,
uh,
you know,
sort of an odd thing.
Uh,
it's,
it's really been going on for eight years.
So I don't quite understand exactly why it's officially odd now.
And it hasn't been for,
you know,
all that time period.
A second.
The second part of that question is,
uh,
W I,
I'll ask it a different way than it was a asked,
which is what's going to be the best performing asset class over the next five
years.
Uh,
or I think that was more or less what you were asking.
Um,
and,
um,
I,
you know,
it's,
it's always hard to tell exactly,
uh,
what,
what that will be.
Uh,
but,
but typically,
you know,
you have to have a view of the world.
And I,
I think our view of the world is that,
you know,
the economies of the developed countries or are going to get hurt,
uh,
over the next year or so ought to drive down asset values,
variety of types.
Uh,
and that,
uh,
there,
there should be a great opportunity,
uh,
out about,
you know,
as sort of a year to start buying companies and other types of assets,
uh,
at,
at what should prove to be a bottom.
Uh,
and then,
um,
uh,
if you can leverage those assets as the economy keeps getting better,
you'll make a really great returns.
The last time,
uh,
this,
set of circumstances presented themselves was 2002,
uh,
after the recession in 2001,
which went into 2002.
And we were the biggest purchaser of,
uh,
of,
companies in the world,
uh,
in 2003 in 2004.
And as a result of that,
the fund that we use to buy those companies,
uh,
earned,
about 51%,
uh,
after fees.
Um,
uh,
which,
um,
for those who keep score of these things is,
is really quite extraordinary.
And we think that kind of cycle is going to repeat itself.
So,
so we would think that that,
you know,
the private equity business and you know,
you,
you're seeing now,
uh,
we've just involved with the deal that professor Shiller mentioned.
Uh,
uh,
you know,
it was in the newspaper this week I guess,
uh,
where,
um,
you know,
we were buying assets,
uh,
from a,
a Citibank loans at discounts and,
you know,
uh,
there'll be opportunities in the debt area over the next year or so.
Uh,
that,
that also ought to be a very good,
yes.
How'd you deal with failures
and how do you make that private equity mobile?
Uh,
the question is how do,
how do,
how do we deal with failure?
Like I like our Argentinian,
uh,
investment in the second part of that was,
and how do we think private equity will evolve in the future?
Uh,
how,
how do we deal with failure?
I really hate failure.
I mean,
it's,
it's deep.
It's visceral.
I really can't stand it.
Uh,
and,
uh,
because I feel so passionately about that.
The,
the,
the people who work at our firm,
uh,
all of whom I've been involved hiring,
understand how I feel about failure.
Uh,
and so,
so we don't have a lot of people around who like failing either one,
because they don't want to disappoint me.
But two,
because I don't hire people who don't feel the same,
right?
So this is like a passion not to fail.
So when we fail,
it's a major,
major,
major event.
Okay?
It's just not a normal thing.
And what we do when we fail,
so we spend enormous time thinking through what did we do wrong?
What should we have seen our,
our processes?
Uh,
good.
did we miss identify a variable that got us,
uh,
or did we identify it and didn't,
didn't,
uh,
evaluate how bad that can be.
We've got that wrong.
Or did we just simply have bad luck where they were like three or four bad
things that can happen?
And they all happened like in,
uh,
in,
in a very rapid period of time.
And,
uh,
you know,
failure is a,
how you manage failure is very important.
And some people manage failure by making,
pretend it didn't happen and they just go about their jobs and people don't pay
attention.
Well we lost money on that one.
I don't believe in that.
I,
I like to learn.
Sometimes you learn more from your failures than you do from your successes.
And,
and we,
we,
we actually changed the way we made decisions at the whole firm after a very
early failure that we had had and changed our whole investment process.
And that one failure created most of our successes.
Right?
So failure when you make a lot of decisions,
I used to think we could make no mistakes.
Uh,
and that's what I always try and do.
but if you're very active in making decisions,
you,
I think about this stuff so much that we probably get about a 90
to 93% of our decisions.
Correct.
Um,
maybe a tiny bit higher,
but that means we failed a lot.
Right?
So to the 7% failure,
sometimes we get 95% right?
But we're still making 5% failure,
you know,
across the firm.
And so we're always struggling to improve.
And get that down to almost like nothing.
Uh,
and,
and so,
you know,
failure is a really important element,
uh,
in learning.
It's like bad dating,
right?
You date somebody,
it doesn't work out.
That's the way,
by the way,
most dating is.
It doesn't work out,
uh,
works out for a while,
then it doesn't work out.
And,
and so all of you would probably think about,
what did I learn from this?
Why,
why did I get involved with this person?
Was this a good thing on balance or not a good thing?
Uh,
you know,
am I gonna repeat this mistake in the future?
What did I learn?
Right?
And that's what we all do in our own lives,
and we do it in our commercial life,
uh,
as well.
Second part of that question was the evolution.
Uh,
on private equity.
Private equity is an enduring asset class because it basically makes really
great returns.
Uh,
it attracts very talented people.
it reallocates capital around the globe.
Uh,
it goes where there's,
um,
uh,
Opportunity,
and,
and it improves companies by investing more capital in these,
uh,
businesses.
Uh,
and so there's a,
there's a,
there's an enduring place,
uh,
for private equity.
Uh,
right now there's a capital crunch and there's not much money available to bar
except on smaller deals.
Uh,
that circumstance happened,
uh,
briefly in 2002,
it happened.
1990,
91 half in 1987 happened.
1982 happen.
1975.
So it happens.
Uh,
and when it happens,
everybody always says,
oh my goodness,
this business is going away and so forth.
And that never ends up occurring because capital always comes back.
Uh,
the evolution of the business.
We'll have a few super bracket kind of firms like ourselves who keep attracting
more and more capital,
who are investing globally,
who have people all over the world.
Uh,
and,
and the future for these kinds of businesses I think is,
uh,
is,
is pretty good.
Um,
quite good.
And,
uh,
um,
you know,
you have smaller firms that are in individual countries.
Uh,
sometimes a segmented,
uh,
by,
um,
uh,
area of concentration.
You know,
you'll have a healthcare,
you know,
group,
uh,
and some of those businesses will do well.
Some were wither.
Uh,
you have smaller firms that do smaller kinds of deals.
There's always a place,
uh,
for,
for that.
Uh,
so,
so I think that,
um,
uh,
private equity tends to grow and step functions,
you know,
uh,
as,
as a function of how much money institutions have to put in the class.
Uh,
when,
uh,
stock markets go down and institutions generally have less money,
they put less money in the class,
uh,
when the markets get better,
they put more money.
So it's not a straight line of growth.
It's a little wavy like that.
And I think that will continue.
I think
what I think we're done.